don't worry this is not becoming Tiger
Beat for libertarians hi I'm Nick
Gillespie with reason TV and today we're
talking with Max borders he's the author
of the new book super wealth why we
should stop worrying about the gap
between rich and poor and he's also the
director of content for the foundation
for economic education and the editor of
The Freeman their legendary publication
max thanks for talking to thank you okay
am super wealth you say it particularly
that we should not mind the gap between
rich and poor why not well what this
fetish isn't about the gap and it
believe it it is it is a fetish you know
you can see media reports every day
about you know people sort of apoplectic
about the gap and why they increasing
gap between rich and poor more and more
poor people fewer and fewer wealthy
people who are massively ripped
massively rich and concentrations of
wealth among as you've heard the one
percent there is naturally there's going
to be gaps in income because some people
do this some people do that this is
worth more or perceived as worth more
some people don't work as hard because
they value some you know late leisure
time or something but how do you you
know how do you explain the gap I mean
is the one percent getting richer
because they deserve it and they're
clean and fresh smelling and they're
anointed by God what's the role of you
know what's the role of public policy
and you know in kind of pumping up the
difference well this is a really big
problem actually and it's one I think we
as libertarians have to take very
seriously and that is that we have a
huge problem in this country with a
difference between makers and takers
between crony capitalists and actual
value creators so on the one hand you've
got people who have figured out how to
game the system they go down here in the
brothels of K Street and figure out how
to change the rules benefit them and we
get massive transfer of wealth from
middle class and poor people to rich
people what are the you know who are the
villains who are the malefactors of
great wealth to get money by gaming the
system well it's it's it's hard to point
at someone and say you're a demon mm-hmm
because I tend to agree
the Nobel laureate North who basically
said if your institutions give rise to
piracy you're going to see a lot of
pirates so the incentive system that we
find ourselves and is important but that
also gives rise to a kind of more venal
side of people if you drop naturally
sort of hungry ambitious people in one
one of two systems one in which you are
rewarded by creating value and one in
which you're rewarded by gaming the
system and right now we have both in
this country what's your sense of income
mobility how how important is that in
discussions about income inequality or
about poverty well one of the good news
is we are still in the United States a
very very upwardly mobile society okay
and this is not what you read though you
you constantly read that because income
is spread the income gap is spreading
mobility must by definition be declining
but that's not actually the case no I
mean if you if you relativize it you
know relative to where we were not only
is purchasing power increase so there's
all kinds of ways to slice it have a
chapter about about statistics called
statistics and sabotage and a great
economist on Boudreaux help me with this
chapter a lot because he's really tuned
into these kind of messages but one of
the things we discover about in income
abilities that people are actually quite
upwardly mobile in the United States and
so really when we think about the
policies that keep people back for
example the minimum wage is one of those
we take off the bottom rungs of the
ladder of their mobility lab ladder we
had those price people out of the labor
market if you say okay out of the box
you have no skills no experience no
resume but we're going to pay you nine
dollars most employers are going to be
like forget it we're not even we're not
talking anymore exactly well let's talk
you know the book again is super wealth
but you're also working at the freeman
you know which is one of the oldest if
not the oldest libertarian publication
tell us you've been editor-in-chief or
in charge of the production of it since
last October what are your goals for the
for the publication one of the mandates
I had coming on was that that was not
open for discussion was
we want to reach out to a younger
audience it had become something of you
know for the intellectual echo chamber
among libertarians and the organ at the
fee the organization had a new mandate
we've got to reach the next generation
with the ideas of liberty then we're not
doing it very well we and so that was my
mandate but I got a lot of people who
were saying oh my gosh what does this
mean what does this mean and I said I
want to say and I want to say to the
audience don't worry this is not be
coming Tiger Beat for libertarians okay
not that that would be so bad as a
former teen magazine editor myself all
right you could do a lot worse what are
what are the areas you know that you're
going to be focusing on do you think in
terms of the coverage fee has a new
motto inspire educate and connect if you
think about the popular Malcolm Gladwell
book the tipping point he talks about in
that book mavens connectors and salesmen
or evangelists those three archetypes
you find in society when those three
archetypes are working very well
together you really do have a good
chance of spreading a message or making
social change so one of the things I try
I'm trying to bring to bear with this is
you know the Freeman is the magazine of
ideas but it should also be in magazine
of inspiration in connection so we want
to we want to do more stuff about people
about stories about people what they're
doing what they're working on because
really young people don't need to be
talked down to where is the best place
for people if they want to get a copy of
the freemen or they want to read more
online where should they go easiest
thing to do feed org feee org you can
click on the Fremen or you can go
straight to the link feed org slash
freeman we are talking with max orders
the author of the new book super wealth
why we should stop worrying about the
gap between rich and poor he's also the
head of the new and improved Freeman max
thanks for talking to reason to go thank
you I'm Nick Gillespie thanks
you